et
on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés anne nivat bonjour anne en sort
face à vos patricia allemonière bonjour
patricia vous avez toutes deux un
couvert le précédent conflit ukrainien
celui du dombass était en 2014 qui
s'était soldée à la fois par la perte de
ces deux républiques perte temporaire
croyais et on à l'époque qui a depuis a
été donc entériné par moscou qui
reconnaît désormais ces deux au blast 2
donne y est et l'ougandaise comme elle
des républiques indépendantes et puis
également l'annexion pure et simple de
la crimée à l'origine à l'époque on s'en
souvient d'une première série de
sanctions décidées par l'union
européenne et les etats-unis à
l'encontre de moscou depuis les choses
évidemment ce sont bien empirer depuis
ce 24 février dernier date du début de
l'invasion russe sur l'ukraine
aujourd'hui où en est-on et bien d'après
les nations unies cette offensive russe
avait fêté hier soir plus de 400 morts
et 800 blessés mais ce bilan est sans
doute raison de sa de la réalité il ne
tient compte que des cas qui peuvent
être confirmées à l'heure où nous
parlons d'après l'ukraine de son école
aurait été endommagé dans les
bombardements le signal que malgré les
dénégations de moscou ya une volonté
délibérée de causer des pertes civiles
côté russe volonté délibérée ou pas
c'est la même chose il y aura des pertes
civiles c'est le cas de toute guerre
j'étais sous les bombes russe dans la
guerre en tchétchénie la propagande
russe disait qu'il ne bombarde pas les
civils je les voyais tomber et je
racontais ce qui se passait ça va être
la même chose en ukraine et plus plus
ils vont vouloir rentrer dans les
grandes villes et là je pense que c'est
cod ça c'est la ville d'odessa le grand
port d'odessa qui est la prochaine cible
plus il y aura des possibilités de
pertes civiles je ne parle même pas de
kiev parce que même avec les les
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
partent il va rester quand même au moins
deux millions de personnes à kiev donc
c'est inévitable qu'il y ait des pertes
civiles inévitable c'est le lot de
chaque guerre donc il faut qu'on s'y
prépare nous allons avoir ces images là
on va évoquer la question des réfugiés
dans un instant mais il ya une autre
question immédiate parce que les
décisions d'aujourd'hui engendre
évidemment des conséquences 2 un faut-il
livrer des armes et des munitions à
l'armée ukrainienne patricia allemonière
face à des russes qui sont accusés
aujourd'hui tout simplement de crimes de
guerre par les âges notamment d'armes à
sous munitions alors c'est la position
qui était prisée cette décision qui a
été prise puisque il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution pour l'europe et les
états unis de dd les ukrainiens que de
leur livrer des armes alors ses
livraisons sont soit
ouvertement déclarée comme les
britanniques qui ont dit deux mille
missiles anti char avec ses des armes
qui sont très efficaces effectivement
est facile d'usagé il y à des pays qui
adoptent une position plus discrètes
comme la france qui ne parlent que de
livraisons d'essence et puis depuis
lille diodes savait que l'iodé peut
servir quand il ya une déflagration
nucléaire pour protéger la thyroïde ap
le 08 mai la france occupe une position
très discrète d'autres fonte et les
tares de s'exposer face à la russie
d'être considérés comme belligérants
demain je ne suis pas dans le secret des
décisions mais il est vrai qu en en
parlant pas on s'expose moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup surpris lassé de ces derniers
ces derniers jours c'est la déclaration
de blinken qui dit haut et fort qu'on le
vin livrer des sukhoï ou des mig via la
pologne allant de l'otan mais les
responsables ont hérité de l'ère
soviétique est donc là c'est exposer la
pologne aux foudres du kremlin assez je
trouve que c'est de cette annonce est
très dangereuse parce que si on veut le
faire je crois que la discrétion
s'impose pour ne pas irriter encore un
peu plus le maître du kremlin comme on
appelle le vladimir poutine déclaration
à considérer ou bien dissuasive à la
destination de moscou
on ne sait plus si vous voulez les
américains les les services secrets
américains avaient prévu tout ce qui
s'est passé on ne les a pas écoutés
aujourd'hui je suis assez d'accord est
ce que vient de dire patricia mai
en même temps on ne sait plus quoi faire
pour pouvoir arrêter vladimir poutine on
ne sait plus si ce que ce que l'on dise
que ça va provoquer chez lui en tout cas
ces livraisons d'armes sont absolument
nécessaires parce qu'il est prouvé sur
le terrain que ces armes par exemple les
gens notamment les mini soja velin aussi
sur les routes les mises aidé à l'épaule
ll y sont des missiles anti temps qui
aide concrètement
les soldats ukrainien l'armée
ukrainienne il faut quand même un
courage extraordinaire moi j'ai vu les
missiles stinger à l'époque des
compagnons de cette chaîne mais là les
combattants ukrainien avec celui ci
j'avais assez anti tanks et il faut si
vous voulez si vous êtes à 50 mètres
c'est encore presque trop loin si si si
le temps qui est devant vous à 15 mètres
là vous l'avez de façon certaine mais
c'est il faut il faut c'est probablement
il faut s'exposer donc mais ça fait la
différence tous les rapports des
militaires américains le disent
aujourd'hui au point que jean yves le
drian parle aujourd'hui d'une possible
défaite pour la russie vous y croyez ou
c'est simplement de la communication ça
écoutez moi ça ne m'amuse pas du tout
qu'on fasse de la communication et qu'on
ne soit pas réaliste je je
tout le monde pensait tout y compris que
l'avancé des russes seraient plus
rapides nous le voyons ça n'est pas tout
à fait le cas donc il y a une certaine
faiblesse qui est due justement à la
résistance ukrainienne qui est due
également à d'autres facteurs mais on ne
sait pas jusqu'où ça va aller tout ce
que l'on sait c'est que les russes ne
s'arrêteront pas là et en tout cas là où
ils sont ils ne se retireront pas
ça c'est très important donc on ne sait
pas jusqu'où 0 mais on sait que là où
ils sont il n'en partiront pas et on est
donc encore bien loin de réussir à avoir
un quelconque corridors humanitaires ou
des négociations qui soit disons
efficace oui puis je crois qu'il ya une
part les bonheurs d'intoxication
beaucoup dans toutes les déclarations
qui sont faites aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'il ya une guerre qui se fait sur le
terrain et puis aussi une guerre avec
les mots avec la grèce la france de
prédire cheikh de la russie ou de jean
yves le drian je crois que la population
sur le terrain a besoin d'encouragements
mobilisation de mobilisation donc ça
fait partie de ces deux on a donn des
missiles contre les chars contre les
regarder les images de cet avion russe
abattu par un stinger à quel point ça
elles sont fortes parce que la mobilit
ça redonne du courage à ce peuple qui se
bat et donc des déclarations en disant
que effectivement l'armée russe pourrait
perdre j'ai su un peu sceptique mais
pourrait perdre et bien ça fait partie
aussi de ses encouragements et qui sont
essentielles aujourd'hui pour l'heure en
tout cas on espère toujours
d'éventuelles négociations qui se
poursuivent à la frontière biélorusse
moscou avait annoncé dans la matinée
l'instauration de cessez-le-feu locaux
et l'ouverture de couloirs pour
permettre l'évacuation des civils de
plusieurs villes dont kiev et kharkiv
problème quatre de ses six couloirs
menait et bien ni plus ni moins que vers
la russie et la biélorussie refus donc
de kiev écoutez la réaction d' emmanuel
macron
les couloirs humanitaires selon claire
c'est la possibilité de faire sortir ces
femmes et ces hommes la russie plaide
pour faire des couloirs humanitaires
vers la russie
je connais pas beaucoup d'ukrainiens qui
est envie d'aller se réfugier en russie
c'est une hypocrisie et donc cette un
artefact de communication que je
réprouve
cynisme eux mêmes comme le dit emmanuel
manager mais la guerre c'est du cynisme
absolu mais de toute façon aujourd'hui
kiev et moscou se font la guerre
donc ils ne peuvent pas se mettre
d'accord sur quoi que ce soit quand ils
sont en pleine guerre surtout j'allais
dire sur un couloir aérien sur un
corridor aérien dans toutes les guerres
c'est extrêmement fragile de ces
histoires de corridors aériens je refais
la comparaison avec la guerre en
tchétchénie et se dérouler quand même à
l'intérieur de la fédération de russie
et non pas dans un état étranger et là
aussi j'ai vu des colonnes de civils qui
était bombardé alors qu'il y avait soit
disant un un corridor humanitaire
donc tout ça ce sont les mots et on a on
a deux guerres mais ça a toujours été le
cas sauf qu'aujourd'hui le côté disons
démo de la propagande est absolument
exacerbée puisqu'on a les médias sociaux
et qu'on connaît tous en temps réel mais
ce qui compte c'est quand même ce qui se
passe sur le terrain c'est ça qui compte
c'est ça qui va et ce qui va avoir un
impact sur une éventuelle possibilité de
faire croire à vladimir poutine qu'il
peut s'en tirer la terre et la tête
haute et c'est là que l'on pourra
négocier avec lui mais on n'y est pas
encore on y parvient on va l'évoqué dans
un instant vous vous parliez d'alep à
l'instant la preuve que les russes ne
savent pas sont indifférents au corridor
humanitaire puisque on n'a jamais vu
d'évacuation de civils dallel il y a eu
des tentatives il y a eu des mots des
buttes de populations aient envie de
garder des groupes de gens qui passaient
avec chaque fois des arts est d'aider
des attaques des tirs et donc qui
empêchait 2016 c'était l'année des
corridors des tentatives de corridors
humanitaires à l'ept négocié avec la
turquie déjà l'icis invite d'ailleurs à
se dire aussi qu aux médias c'était très
compliqué mais ce qu'on a toujours
remarqué c'est que vladimir poutine
souvent mais gossip des corridors
humanitaires au moment où il frappe au
maximum
vraiment le cas d'alex il est en train
de négocier astana alors qu'il frappait
avec les afghans et qu'il faisait ce que
certains ont appelé le parking c'est
terrible et juste moi ce soir je suis
très inquiète pour la ville de marioupol
il ya beaucoup de civils dans cette
ville et dire à ces gens là a expliqué
vous pouvez partir et encore c'est des
mots je ne sais pas si ça pouvait se
passer pour aller voir les télévisions
russes qui vous attendent de l'autre
côté de la frontière en russie je trouve
que ça si ça fait pas partie de ce qu'on
peut appeler des crimes de guerre eh
bien je ne sais pas ce qu'on peut
appeler un crime de guerre oui je suis
d'accord c'est très mauvais signe c'est
très mauvais signe qu'on parle de
corridors côté russe qu'on veuille des
corridors parce que ça veut dire qu'ils
vont pilonner ils vont pilonner les
villes et ce sera des dizaines de
milliers de morts évidemment donc c'est
ça qui va se passer ça va se passer à
marioupol c'est en train de se passer ça
début mais on a d'autres villes encore
plus importantes comme au dessin et qui
ont peut on ne sais pas peut-être que en
arrivant au dessin bléneau poutine va
avoir envie de faire la jonction avec la
transnistrie
7,7 et l'excès de la vie annexe et de la
moldavie depuis 1992 dans lequel
stationnent des soldats russes dont la
moldavie nôtres mais la moldavie est
très préoccupée de ce qui se passe
blinken s'est rendu en moldavie où là il
ya une femme présidente et une femme
premier ministre en moldavie qui sont
très pro européenne qui sont très
préoccupés donc
voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui même
si on a l'impression que du côté de kiev
ça s'est un peu calmé parce que
justement il y à une forte résistance et
que vladimir poutine est dérouté dans
ses plans
krainer vaste justement c'est pas du
tout le territoire de la tchétchénie qui
était minuscule comme un mouchoir de
poche d'un grand que la france
l'ukraine donc il y a de la déroute il y
a des problèmes d'approvisionnement
venir poutine a quand même dans son
dernier discours demandé une minute de
silence raphaël il ne le fait jamais une
minute de silence pour les pertes russe
alors il n'a pas dit combien de pertes
aux russes et tout le monde se dispute
sur les chiffres mais si vladimir
poutine qui quelques vingt quatre heures
auparavant disais que tu es criminels
ceux qui parlaient des pertes aux rudes
en parle lui même sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et il prépare
son opinion publique et que l'opinion
publique sait et que les mères on se
souvient le mouvement des mères de
soldats des mères de soldats à quel
point c'était important il ya quel point
c'était ça a perturbé le régime est là
aujourd'hui on voit l'inquiétude les
lumières cuisine par rapport à justement
à cette question des mères d'être là
parce que outre les menaces
d'emprisonnement et de tout ce qui
existe ils apprennent il a annoncé qu'il
allait verser des compensations
financières de plusieurs dizaines des
milliers d'euros aux familles de
disparus
donc ça sous-entend que si la la
répression ne peut pas les faire taire
il espère que l'argent pour aller
chercher un truc ça prouve son intense
qu'il y ait un climat de contestation
l'attend russie justement j'allais le
dire vendredi une déclaration d'une
sénatrice est passée presque inaperçue
mais elle est capitale cette sénatrice
elle s'appelle ludmila naruto va elle
est la veuve du maire de saint
petersbourg anatoli sobtchak qui avaient
été assassinés et lé pardon les pouces
elle est la veuve et elle est la mère de
une jeune femme qui s'appelle sortie no
76 kg 100 kg et qui a été candidate
d'ailleurs la vie et sur une seule
longueur une héroïne de la télé réalité
qui est devenue une journaliste qu'est
devenu journaliste à la télévision
d'opposition dodge qui est fermée qui a
plusieurs millions de dhs abonnés sur
son compte instagram que je suis et 7 sa
mère donc est quand même une officielle
elle est sénatrice elle était le elle a
dit quelque chose elle a osé dire
que d'après ces sources à elle sur tout
un bataillon il n'y avait que quatre
survivants elle l'a dit et sa fille a
dit sur son compte instagram que elle
elle était très fière du courage de sa
mère mais qu'elle avait peur pour elle
alors il se passe rien pour le moment
avec cette sénatrice mais comme on sait
venir poutine est un homme patient et la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid
et l'information n'est plus libre
aujourd'hui en russie on doit s'en tenir
au langage officiel de l'armée sous
peine évidemment de se voir interdit
d'antenne ou ou de presse merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on y va merci
également à patricia allemonière qui
était à nos côtés aujourd'hui on veut